body odor the middle seat burnt toast
public bathrooms so what do these all
have in common that's right they're all
arguably better than LinkedIn's website
okay perhaps a slight exaggeration but
look at this place
it's like level 10 of pac-man or at
least it used to be for the first time
in years linking is finally giving this
place a major makeover and streamlining
features just like it did with your
mobile app now with the website actually
usable it's a great place to catch up on
industry news and connect with people if
you aren't using this social network you
should be and you should start with the
Home tab or LinkedIn's version of the
news feed it's now less cluttered with
promotional Linkedin junk and ads
although there are still some peculiar
ads over here reporting and the FBI
don't seem like a good fit if you aren't
happy with the content in your feed
click the three buttons in the top right
of the post to hide or unfollow people
the most improved award goes to the my
network tab no more of those annoying
unread notifications that never go away
you can have more easily accept friend
requests but don't send requests from
this page if you do you'll be sending
the dreaded please join my professional
network email instead go to the person's
profile page click connect and type out
a personal invitation and while you're
at it make sure to update your profile
write a good headline a short keyword
heavy sentence about what you do and
don't forget a current of course
professional profile photo is it
completely perfect around here no for
instance
LinkedIn tries to get you to upgrade to
its premium service just about
everywhere but the website and the
service are worth more of your time now
and certainly don't belong in the
company of the
Thanks